socialist Bernie Sanders and Alexandria
Castillo Cortez teaming up yet again to
push their left-wing agenda this time
they're demanding that the government
declared climate change a national
emergency and they're calling for a
massive mobilization of federal
resources to deal with it here's Bernie
Sanders ramping up the climate hysteria
with this comparison I'm reminded
today's in terms of the crisis that we
face in climate change about where the
United States was in 1941 when it was
attacked at Pearl Harbor and what
happened at that point having to fight a
war on two fronts the easily and in
Europe the United States came together
and within three years it had created
the type of armaments program that was
necessary to in fact win the war or any
crazy
Dayna win the war right Pearl Harbor I
don't know look here you know why he
wants Alexandra Caza Cortez to help him
because he absolutely needs her his
campaign is almost invisible
it's amazing you think about the debates
nobody talked about him in the debates
nobody's talked about him since he had a
pretty good fundraising number nobody
even talked about that so he has got to
figure out a way to help me to have some
relevance and if I were Elizabeth Warren
I might just want a OC to go to Bernie's
right like I don't I wouldn't want that
endorsement like let him have that
because this is not working out that
well for Bernie this time around no I
said I said that a while ago that if you
if you get a OCS endorsement you own
that craziness or whatever that she
might say that day that's idiotic or
irrational or whatever but Greg how do
you run on I'm gonna fight climate
change because these candidates
essentially are telling the American
people your gasoline is gonna be six
seven eight dollars a gallon we're gonna
tell you what kind of car to drive and
you might actually lose your job if you
work even anywhere near the energy in
energy industry before I address that
kudos to Bernie Sanders comparing
climate change to Pearl Harbor is an
improvement he didn't say the Holocaust
which has been the usual go-to analogy
for the far-left whenever it's something
is bad it's like Hitler or it's the
Holocaust so maybe they're learning that
to choose other things but Pearl Harbor
still pretty bad
fear is the quickest way to get to your
pocketbook and they take an issue and
they make they make taxation the only
solution to your point their demands
when you're talking about gasoline can
only be endured by the white rich let's
face it it's a white liberal rich the
top stars of the world that can endure
these climate change restrictions but
it's gonna harm the lives of minorities
right this is the most anti minority
issue blue-collar Americans as well if
you're talking about eliminating jobs
restricting modes of transportation
increasing prices on basic living needs
like gasoline these are things that rich
white people can just shrug off and go
and then feel really good about the fact
that they have a Tesla and they could
feel really good that they you know have
solar panels because it's totally
affordable to them and then everybody
else is like about an offset yes yeah
they bought carbon offsets I that's it
you know I love this show because I
learn about white privilege from great
yes they get discounts want to pay for
the privilege because of all the tax
credits they've got the tax breaks it is
that this is like double jeopardy anyway
I think that you guys are right about
Bernie I you know I don't think we're
talking about him I don't think that he
is moving ahead in this campaign but I
just think that this is you know to me
sounding the alarm I think when you have
90 degrees in Alaska this summer and you
have hail in Guadalajara in Mexico I
think people think something's going on
flooding other crops you can reverse
that one like that you laugh at people
you laugh at Republicans who say oh it's
so cold
thanks global warming it's the same
thing you can't you can't play both
something's going on with it with 90
degrees in Alaska
weather had nothing to do with climate
change it does have something to do with
I think I think they're sounding the
alarm I don't think there's much of a
price to pay for it in terms of the
Democratic primary process I do think
it's a very proactive talking point for
Bernie he's gonna take it out on the
campaign trail and it will resonate
Jesse listen one it's it's okay to sound
the alarm
yes but then when you say everyone's
gonna die if you don't give me all of
your money that's not sounding alarm
that's a fear tactic but they do this
all the time the Democrats use death to
motivate they say you know they're gonna
throw granny over the cliff tax cuts
kill you police kill you
capitalism kills you you know the
weather is a kamikaze pilot by the way
Bernie should apologize to the Japanese
very insensitive analogy comparing
climate change to Pearl Harbor I think
he owes them an apology I'm just I'm
just glad Juan didn't say very sensitive
to these issues he's just starting a
conversation because my head would have
exploded I didn't that's what we know
that's what
[Music]